saludos en esta ocasión nos piden
multiplicar 65 por 1 esto yo lo puedo
escribir 65
puedo usar la equis simbolizando la
multiplicación o también puede usar el
punto para indicar la multiplicación y
aquí lo voy a multiplicar por 1 aquí hay
dos formas de interpretar esto podemos
ver al 65 que se repite una vez o al
número 1 sumado 65 veces de cualquier
manera el resultado va a ser igual a 65
cualquier cosa multiplicada por uno va a
ser igual a esa misma cosa
por ejemplo imaginemos que yo aquí tengo
un espacio en donde puedo escribir
cualquier número y aquí este número que
escriba lo voy a multiplicar por
el resultado de esta multiplicación va a
ser igual al número que escribí en este
espacio por lo que el resultado va a ser
aquí el mismo por ejemplo si yo tengo un
3 acá 3 por 1 va a ser igual a 3 si en
cambio tengo un 157 157 por 1 va a ser
igual a 157
el mismo la misma cantidad otro ejemplo
es losas y yo tengo aquí un 55 por 1 va
a ser igual a 5 y creo que con esto
ustedes ya captan la idea